to say that professor green has faced
and overcome adversity in his life is
such a gross understatement
he's self-aware he's honest he's
critical of himself where he feels he
needs to be
i've got to do some work on myself here
things need to change so as you push
things down they coming sideways i can't
keep projecting my problems onto other
people and blaming them
you know what if i ever see you again
i'm gonna knock you out
and people are like wow do you wish you
could go back in time and change what
your last words to
him were no of course not because that
anger was just
it was that constant it was him being in
and out of my life
him being such a kind generous gorgeous
man but being such a [ __ ] father i felt
like he was
threatening me and i felt like i was
right to stand my ground i didn't expect
that five minutes after that he'd walk
up behind me and put a broken bottle in
my neck
i got my phone i called my name and i
just apologized for all the work she had
put into me
that this was how it was going to end
[Music]
to say that professor green aka stephen
manderson has faced an overcome
adversity in his life is such a gross
understatement there's
moments in this podcast today where you
realize
how unfortunate his life has been at
certain moments
and how much of a seemingly unfair start
he had
that it almost doesn't seem like it can
be true
and we know professor green we know his
music i grew up listening to professor
green's music we know his
documentaries more recently and how
inspiring and
vulnerable those documentaries have been
and most of us will know about the
tragedy that met him
in his early years when his dad decided
to commit suicide
but it's interesting to see how all of
these events came to shape this man a
man that is empathetic
a man that refuses to be bitter and a
man that has overcome
and thrived despite all of this
professor green is a remarkable person
he's a remarkable guy he's self-aware
he's honest he's critical of himself
where he feels he needs to be
and because of that because of the
content the documentaries and the music
he's made he's one of my
sincere inspirations especially as it
relates to mental health
and the change that he's been able to
make in the conversation this is a
an honest conversation today and it's
one that i think everybody should and
needs to hear
especially men especially in the world
we live in
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the director ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please
keep this to yourself
[Music]
i did a lot of research on you
and i i've listened to podcasts you've
done and i've
read um parts from the book that you you
authored
and i i want to know from your
perspective what you think the most
pivotal moments were from your
early years that came to shape the man
that you became later in your life
wow let's start with the big ones yeah
we went straight into the waiting
small talk to her it would be really
easy to draw from
uh some of the the more dramatic events
i think because they're the more obvious
um and they're they're highlighted quite
often they come up in conversation all
the time but i think
i don't think that their specific
moments in the same way i think the the
worst traumas that i actually endured
weren't
any single moments they were cumulative
they were things that happened over time
um i think it was probably more a case
of
my or what shaped me
being cumulative as well it was the time
that i spent
with my great grandmother i was sort of
a six of us in the flat when i was born
there was
me my great-grandmother my grandmother
my mother and my two uncles so my nan's
three kids
my mum was the first person to leave the
house when i was a year old
she was a consistent she know she was
she was there consistently throughout my
life but my name was my legal guardian
when i was by the time i was three
and at a point where my nan could have
started a new life for herself
she took on the responsibility of of her
mum
and her grandson but it was amazing
because
you know apart from the ancestral [ __ ]
sorry the ancestral shirt yeah well just
you know you think like my
great-grandmother went through two world
wars whatever
relationship she had been through the
relationship that she had with my
grandmother
all the problems that they had as a
mother and daughter the problems that my
nan had
with my mother the problems that my
mother had with my grandmother what were
these problems
um i couldn't tell you because they
weren't my problems but they existed
and i was aware because there were
arguments and there was stress and there
was shouting and there were financial
problems and struggles
and there was robin peter to pay paul me
being shuffled off into a room when
you know a money lender had come around
to you know pick up money and
conversations and
that i wasn't supposed to be privy to
but in a three-bedroom flat it was about
as big as a room that we're sitting and
it was quite difficult to
avoid being aware of these things um but
there was a lot of good people who skype
must be really tough growing up in
hackney but
i didn't have i didn't know anything i
didn't know any different
you know it wasn't like i grew up in
wheelchair until i was 13 and then it
was just
airlifted and dropped off in hackney and
told to survive you know it was all i
knew
but in hindsight there was a lot that
wasn't mine to take on but that i
absorbed that that stress and that
anxiety definitely seeped into me and i
was a very anxious child
i was always man i got a tummy ache but
at the same time i was really fortunate
because when
when people talk about you know kids who
aren't brought up by
a or both parents they normally miss out
on the nurturing that i definitely
didn't because
my great-grandmother was always at home
she hardly left the house
not least of all because of her age um
and that time i got to spend with her
it is probably what
made the larger part of what good is in
me or encouraged the good in me you know
i would run out into the living room
which was where she slept on a chair
that folded out
every morning when that weird holding
screen was on the bbc with a little girl
holding that
puppet with that which in hindsight is
quite scary
you're really weird um but before the
cartoons would come on and you know she
would read to me i always remember her
blue blanket that i'd jump underneath
and she taught me to read well ahead of
my years you know basic numeracy and
stuff when i went to school i was ahead
of most kids because of that time spent
with my great grandmother and i enjoyed
learning so i saw validation in
the right places rather than throwing
tantrums at school like a lot of people
did because they weren't getting
attention
you know in single parent homes parents
have a tough decision to make do i go
out and work
and lose out on the time of my child but
be able to provide or do i lose out on
the money that i would make which would
make supporting
a child easier it's a you know that's a
conundrum that's a really difficult
situation to be in
i was really fortunate i didn't lose out
on that
and i think it's that that's what shaped
me you know it wasn't
any of any single event really it was
that period of time
and you said your mum was the first to
leave the house yeah she
so my mom was 16 when she had me um wow
yeah
my dad was 18. they were separated very
quickly
um and my mum had a lot of growing to do
i'm more than twice her age and i've
just become a father
i can't imagine you know being a parent
or having tried to have been a parent
when i was 16. i don't know
yeah 16 yeah my crazy age to
well you're a baby yourself aren't you
16 it's like very much so yeah
and how was your what was your
relationship like with your mum from
that point onwards um so
me and my mum we've had an on-and-off
relationship in in the latter years of
my life
i don't talk about it too much um
loads of stuff about how they're about
my relationship or lack there over my
dad because of how his life ended
um but you know i always i was brought
up to not air
dirty laundry and my mom did try she did
you know and like i said she was a much
more uh she was a much
more consistent part of my life than my
dad was
you know she made she made the effort
has it taken you some time to get to the
point where you can be
compassionate about
your experiences with her i think it's
taken me some time to get to the point
where i can be compassionate about my
experiences with everyone
that i was involved with growing up um
and i think i got to that place quite a
while ago
and it's quite it's quite liberating man
it it's it's quite freeing because
that i think holding on to anger you
know it becomes resentment
and that leads to bitterness and and
bitter is not something i'm interested
in being i think a lot of people
get you know end up quite bitter and
jaded quite early on and that determines
the rest of their lives
and i used to be
quite scared to even say the words i'm
happy because i would worry about what
was round the corners that i couldn't
see around now
i'm never gonna develop the power to see
around corners
um and worrying about what's out of your
control
um and preempting things that may or may
not happen
is not the healthiest way to live um
it's not great for your mental health
it's not great for the quality of life
that you have because if you're
constantly worrying you know
i can enjoy a lot of what um or be happy
about a lot of the things that i've
achieved
with hindsight but actually when i was
going through the early years of
of my of the successful part of my music
career
there was a lot of things that i didn't
enjoy in the moment as much as i should
because i was worried about dropping the
ball
because i experienced loss quite early
on um
and come from quite a disadvantaged
background and i wasn't used to a lot of
things i was starting to encounter i was
scared of of loss and of losing it and
dropping the ball you know it's why
i didn't take holidays i would attach a
few days here and there on to work
but i felt i was you know scared to
enjoy myself or to
to let go of that kind of almost
incessant need to keep working
because i was worried about losing it
but i wasn't enjoying what i had so did
i ever really
have it um and it took me a while to get
to a point where
you know i'm in a place where i enjoy
things as they happen and life is a lot
more pleasant because
i don't spend my time catastrophizing
about what may or may not happen
um not least of all because i've
survived things you know and i know that
[ __ ] does hit the fan and things do
happen it's quite likely that i'm gonna
get through them
so i can worry about them happening and
ruin my life
day by day because all i do is worry
about what may or may not happen which
is also distracting and doesn't allow me
then to focus on the things that are in
front of me and that are important
which will build a happier a steadier a
more consistent life for me
or i can i can deal with things as they
come
knowing that i have the strength and the
resilience in myself to handle things
um and it's taken me a while to get to
that point it's taking some therapy as
well
but it's kind of it it's it you know
i i feel quite calm and relaxed in
saying right now that i am
happy and i feel quite secure and that i
can handle
what may or may not come my way talk
about worry then you referenced earlier
you'd say to your i think your nan that
you had a like a pain in your belly yeah
and i guess you didn't really know what
that was when you were younger nope
what did you come to learn about that
pain in your belly and it was anxiety it
was a night in my stomach the problem
was
i was born with a problem in my
digestive tract i had
um called i don't know if it was a
procedure that was called pyloric
stenosis or the condition but stenosis
is
narrowing and my stomach basically your
pile of muscle at the bottom of your
stomach should open and close to let
food pass but mine was just closed so
it's six weeks old i have an operation
which has left me with a scar that goes
from there to there
um so whenever i said now i've got a
bellyache i've got a tummy ache man i
got tummy ache it was straight to the
doctors
um and that then
meant that i would go to the hospital
and have cameras up me
down me you know be put into machines to
be scanned to make sure there wasn't
something physically wrong which there
wasn't it was psychological um i was
diagnosed with ibs
really early on and that's still quite
misunderstood
you know is it something psychological
that manifests physically or is it
physical and causes mental
problems um and i think that really
highlights the intrinsic link between
the gut and the brain um and it
again i guess that's a bit of a chicken
and egg situation
never really considered that before
never really ever considered that there
might there might be a link between the
two
um and with ibs especially it's
something that i've
become increasingly curious about
because as i said to you before you
start recording i've definitely got a
problem with my gut i just haven't
figured out quite yet what it is
um going back to your sort of your
formative years was there anything else
through that period that
would shape the man you you became that
you can really think of between the age
of like i don't know
0 and 16 like school life and stuff like
that and
yeah um so i was i was quite a bright
kid
um and you sound surprised
most people i sit here don't seem to be
especially people that come from
that kind of background don't don't tend
to be that academic their smarts and
genius teams seems to come from other
creative sources or they're like like
yesterday we had to wrestle russell kane
and he's just like a
you know comedic genius and then became
a bit more academic when he left school
but you know i've kind of i i
i guess there's i've kind of gone full
circle in that i have to use the
academic part of my brain and what i do
now more than i have done for the last
10 years during making music um
but that wasn't really harnessed it
wasn't you know education wasn't big in
my family no one had been to university
so
me being as bright as i was i wasn't
pushed as as hard as i as i should have
been because my nan sympathized with
my situation my dad being in and out of
my life me being a very sensitive child
my mum not bringing me up um and that
all
quite clearly affecting me um my only
problem at school was ever
the only problem i ever had at school
was was my attendance
um and i went from you know leaving
primary school
with the opportunity to sit the exam for
some pools
to at the age of 11 to a pupil referral
unit by the time i was 13.
um because of attendance yeah because of
attendance
and by that point you know at 13 i
didn't really draw
uh i didn't really join the dots or draw
a parallel between the two things
happening but my great-grandmother
passed when i was 13.
um and that was very very difficult for
me
because she was the person who if she
said to me that everything was going to
be all right she was the one person i
believed up until that point when i
realized that sometimes it
isn't um and some of her last words to
me
when we were in the ambulance on the way
to the hospital where
i can't fight forever and i knew at that
point that was her
saying hey i've had my innings and she
was 90. she had a good innings two world
wars
one world cup um i can't fight forever
yeah what was she what was she what was
the context of her saying that to you
um i believe that was her saying that
she had made her peace
you know she she had you know she lived
with
arthritis diabetes um
we made a good stock though you know to
go through what she went through a metal
plate in her legs she got run over when
she was 19.
um i believe she she was um
and this is only stuff i've started to
find out recently she was
um placed on a doorstep when she was a
baby and she was brought up in
foster care uh her sister wasn't i
didn't even know she had a sister until
recently
um and you know we talk about ancestral
[ __ ] you can see where these things
start to
you see these things start and come from
and you know the issues that
abandonment and detachment cause they're
they're more than just social issues
they
impact development i can just see
how it a lot of my family experienced a
lot of trauma early on from my great
grandmother to my grandmother to my
mother to my dad they all had
pretty difficult childhoods my dad ended
up in care because he was the six of six
children and his mum walked out
um so he was in care for the first few
years of his life he was also born a
twin his twin
died at birth my namesake
my uncle who i never met steven died
when he was 19 went into a diabetic coma
and passed away two years before
my dad took his own life his brother
took his own life in the same way
in the year in between that of them to
taking their own lives he lost his
sister
to cancer that he was the last possible
donor for and he wasn't suitable there
was
you know there's trauma's been a pretty
the trauma's been pretty constant
throughout
almost almost all of my elders
quick one starting from the minute the
lockdown is lifted we're going to start
bringing in some of our subscribers to
watch how this podcast is produced
behind the scenes
means you get to meet the guests meet
myself and see how we put all of this
together
if you want that to be you all you've
got to do hit the subscribe button
when you think about all that's happened
in your sort of generational cycles and
with your elders
and then this is me just thinking like
if had i been through that i would i
think i'd
i'd be overly conscious about how
i maybe unconsciously um
can work to make sure that my you know
you've just had a boy right can make
sure that it like stops with me right
like you know what i mean as much
because yeah i mean i see it in my own
family i see that i've
there's parts of my parents that i've
become that i don't love
you know and i don't and i'm and i you
know what and my parents were actually
really
um un affectionate relatively
unaffectionate and
quite vacant i still call them by their
first names and i find it really awkward
to call them mom and dad like i've
i've never in 27 years looked at my mum
or dad and called the mum or dad ever
not once ever never crazy and even like
i i i'm not close to them at all and i'm
terrified by the prospect
that when i have my kid same thing will
happen
um so that's what i want to ask is like
i would be like what are you what's your
thinking and your like concerns when you
think about your child and making sure
those generational cycles
end with you um my concerns are
uh i mean my concern that
around that to be like 100 honest that
there
there aren't any um i had i've had
a child years before now i think there
would have been many
but i've done a hell of a lot of work on
on trying to understand myself trying to
it's weird right you spend so much time
learning and then you get to a point
where you're like now i've got to
unlearn
all of this [ __ ] because if you're if
you're fortunate enough to be smart
enough to be able to take a long hard
look at yourself
and you're self-aware which is painful
at times but then you can put your hands
up and you can own
your behaviors um and you you know you
can take responsibility for your choices
and your decisions and
you know you go through relationships
and i found that points i was finding
the same person
in a different body oh yeah yeah and
then you know the same problems occur in
the relationship but
what's you know what's the common thread
throughout that narrative i am the
common denominator so i can't
keep projecting my problems onto other
people and blaming them for just being
themselves
i've got to do some work on myself here
things need to change and that well
one thing needs to change me how do i do
that
i have to understand myself better i
have to understand my behaviors i have
to understand my insecurities it's hard
to do
it is because it's the most this you
know it's that kind of
i've never had this anxiety dream i've
only ever had the one where
i can't stop pulling teeth out of my
mouth like and even in a dream going
okay i know i don't have that many teeth
but they're still coming out
but it's that whole like kind of all of
a sudden you're naked in front of your
entire school
if you're going to go and see a
therapist it look you have to go in and
be honest you can't lie to a therapist
um otherwise it won't work and so you
have to explore your deeper most
darkest and and frightening insecurities
in order to understand why certain
why you have certain behaviors why you
respond so defensively in situations
what makes you insecure what did you how
did you go on so that process of
unlearning
all the [ __ ] you had to unlearn and like
turning the lights on i guess
yeah that started with therapy i think
it started before therapy
i don't think it i wasn't ready for
therapy until i started to do some of
that work myself
i think like you similarly i have grown
up
uh with the mindset that i can do
everything on my own
which is uh is it is
it i mean it's definitely helped me
achieve a hell of a lot
but it it also has put distance between
me and people that it shouldn't have
and it's also made it hard for me to
develop lasting relationships
in at points in my life um some which
you know i i look back on and think i
could have i could have done better
i could have been better um all the key
things you had to unlearn
through that process though about
yourself mine was mainly defensiveness
really defensiveness and i kind of want
to
i guess the attendance thing is that
that played out throughout my life i
found it very very difficult to finish
things um
and you know so i would always have
ideas i would always begin things i
would get to a point where that sort of
you know i didn't have my my nana as
she wasn't as present a figure is for me
to be able to just go now i've got a
tummy ache but i would still get
that feeling which would make me want to
withdraw and would make things harder
despite that i've managed to kind of use
that same energy and this is why i think
you know stress is
comes down to perspective because work
can be stressed or work can just be work
right it depends on your perception of
it and so my anxiety can be anxiety or
it can be nervous energy
and energy is what you need to get [ __ ]
done and
i've done a lot of work around mental
health not least of all because of my
encounters with my own problems but also
what first made me aware of even the
phrase mental health was that my father
took his own life
and that work kind of
i think around the conversation
of mental health um and encouraging
people to be more open and honest
with their sensitivities you should be
open to everyone be smart enough to be
open to the people that you can trust
because if you're open to everyone that
you're
opening yourself up to be taken
advantage of um
but the word the one thing that goes
missing in that conversation or two of
all too often is resilience resilience
is incredibly important and
i think the only time that you can learn
or become
resilient without going through trauma
and surviving it
is therapy when you're not at a point of
crisis
so that's why i was saying i did i had
to do some of the work on my own for me
to be able to go to therapy
and then be able to grow through that
because if you just go to therapy when
you're at a point of crisis it's like
waiting until you get sick to go to a
doctor
you know i try now to take a more
proactive you know pro
a proactive approach to my own health
and that's not just my physical
well-being that's my mental well-being
ultimately they should be one in the
same it's just health
um but i think we have a very reactive
nature to most things in
in in western culture we're not
encouraged to be proactive
and we also probably have a foolish
sense of optimism about
how life will unfold right we think
it'll all be okay our health will be
fine
we think we'll never really get old
because it kind of creeps up on you so
it's crept up on me i'm saying
hey andy i looked in the mirror the
other day i saw gray hairs i was like
what the [ __ ] is going on here
i love it though what makes me laugh
right people always
moan about getting older yeah and i'm
just i'm very like i
i can be quite simple in a matter of
fact about things and it's just like
well okay
the alternative is you die right that's
the only way you stop getting older is
you die
so what's you know unless you're
biohacking you're trying to
lengthen your telomeres um but you know
it's
i just think growing old is is great
growing older
is great if you can do it with with
i don't know with i guess we not just
with good intention i've always had good
intentions but i've made a lot of bad
decisions i think
growing older once you get to a point
where you feel happy and comfortable in
your skin
is is it makes it easier yeah i'm not
stressed about getting older because i'm
really happy with who i'm becoming
that's exactly it that's exactly it when
i uh this sounds like a [ __ ] weird
thing to say i said okay
but like when i looked in the mirror of
the day and i saw gray hairs
it's funny because the most comforting
thought that i had was like
but i'm happy and like you know it's the
same thing it's like
i'm getting older yeah but i'm happy and
i'm i'm doing myself justice what i mean
by doing myself justice is like i'm
living my life
yeah i'm like being myself yeah and so
i'm happy to get you know the worst
possible scenario would be i look in the
mirror i see gray hairs
and i've been working at [ __ ] kpmg
because my mom said that was a success
and i'm like i'm on my way to a midlife
crisis i'm not being myself i've not
pursued my dreams
if so feel like the clock is ticking but
when i look in the mirror because i feel
like i'm
i'm living my true self i'm like cool
every time i
you know they add another number to my
age i'm like cool ultimately i'm like
cool because it's
because i'm living my you know and
that's this sounds like a very
interesting thing to say but it's also
one of the things that's made me not
fear death like i used to yes i'm scared
of death
yeah because i guess it's getting to the
point of
your life where you feel as though and i
do wonder if this played a part in what
my dad did getting to a point in life
where you think you can't start over
i'm too old to make the decisions i wish
i made um and it makes me
it's given me more
i guess more my comfort's a wrong word
but like
i've always been quite happy to fall on
a sword as long as it's my own
yeah yeah and i'm always more
scared about having and look i worked 10
years back
speculatively you know as far as music
you know from 18 to 28 it was 28 when i
first sold the record i had people
around me going come on bro man you've
got a fantastic announced to do
um and i just i don't know if there was
like a bit of
of self-belief buried beneath all of the
insecurities that kept me going or if it
was just blind stupidity or a
combination of the two but i kept
going because i wanted it so badly and i
loved it
i loved it i really really loved it
there was nothing in my life at that
point that made me shake my hands like
writing a good lyric
you know that type of excitement when
you nail something you know you're
walking around the room
trying to get that last line of
something and then you get it and you're
like
that feeling is not something that i get
from
you know many aspects of my life um
and so i i continued and
i think it's something that's it's quite
it's not the easiest thing to do is it
when you've got
especially if you're from a
disadvantaged background because you
don't have a fullback or a plan b
or a grandparent that will die and leave
you inherit and so as you set you don't
have that security
but at the same time you know i know a
lot of people with that security who
don't push for anything
and every time i talk to them they've
got a different idea and a different
business venture but they execute and
achieve nothing
because they don't have to yeah yeah
yeah
it does you know i think there's there's
two sides to that coin you know if you
grow up
entirely comfortable do you ever want to
push
that hard to get to where you want to
get to
it's interesting because that hunger of
not having it is is also an advantage as
is the
the you know the privilege of having it
i spend a lot of time talking about
huell on this podcast because they're
the sponsor of the podcast and i'm also
on the board at huell
i'm also an investor in the company but
um i've made a transition
recently not a transition i'd say an
addition to my huel
diet i've been drinking the rtd they're
ready to drink yours for a long time now
but as summer approaches
and as my goals my fitness and my health
goals have
started to shift a little bit i've
become obsessed with
huel's black edition specifically the
vanilla flavor
the difference with the black edition is
there's 50
less carbs there's 33 more protein in it
zero
artificial sweeteners and it's naturally
gluten free so if you're
looking to lean up dare i say for summer
then try the black edition vanilla
flavor it's really really helped me lean
up and
i always you know take my top off on
this podcast to prove to you i'm not
going to do that today
but i take my word for it it's had such
a radical impact on
um the amount of carbs and
visible fats that you can see on me
highly highly recommend trying
black edition vanilla flavor if you've
got goals to lean up for summer to
consume less carbs and to get more
protein
you mentioned your dad there and i
watched the documentary you made
where you um i watched it i think there
was two separate documentaries that i
saw
um about the topic and you went on the
journey of understanding
him um the life he lived and why he made
the choices he he ultimately did
can you tell me what you you learned
through that process yeah
um quite concisely as well at the point
i'm at now and it's that i think the
difference between someone who will
take their own life and someone who
won't is the ability to tolerate how you
feel
at any given time and i've had moments
where i wanted to scratch my skin off
but i've never
contemplated suicide you know
i've never suffered suicidal ideation
there's
there's there's a big difference between
lows
and also i think you know there's
something that's quite scary is the
hyper awareness that people have now
around everything everything has a tag
everything has a name everything is a
condition and i think
we're getting to a point now where you
need awareness before understanding
and then you know awareness
understanding action to me that's
the um the train of things whether it's
you know
let's keep the depression like i think
now there's a conversation around it but
how much is being actioned
not enough yet but i do think it comes
down to being able to tolerate
how you feel because like i i've
at my very lowest lows i've come out by
carrying on
and my dad got to a point where where he
couldn't and there wasn't the support
around him
to to help him in those moments and
sometimes i think even if the support is
there
that choice is is that person's
it just seems so unthinkable
but be lucky for that yeah yeah you're
right i've just spent
the longest amount so when i start first
started hearing about mental health
which is probably about 10 years ago
yeah when i was about i don't know 16
18 maybe the term started to emerge yeah
it wasn't just he's meant or she's made
yeah it was you're crazy or whatever
yeah and then it
thankfully it's the stigma slightly
because it's changed over time
and i just have always struggled
to um
to understand and this is why it's
almost become the strange thing to say
but a bit of an obsession of mine
to understand the position someone must
be in
to believe that to feel that that is a
better outcome for them
it's just and this is why it was so
powerful watching the documentary
because
you know even when you were doing a role
play with the the guy in the chair and
you
you were being the um the the friend and
the guy was sat in the chair
he was the you went to the clinic where
they helped people who have
having suicidal ideation yeah and and
just even in the role-play session i was
like
oh god this is unthinkable it's just
something that i think someone who has
had the privilege
of good mental health will always
struggle to understand
and that's a problem because if you
can't empathize with it properly we
can't i don't think address it properly
you can i think you can empathize
without understanding
yeah that's true yeah you know and i
think we all too often we we want to fix
things
soon someone says they're sad you're
like come on cheer up yeah that's not
helpful
that's what i mean i'm like i'm like
okay be upset what's
you know let's go through this you have
to kind of go through the upset rather
than
trying to suppress it yeah as you push
things down they coming sideways
yeah um it's i think
you know when my dad took his own life
one of the first things i wanted to do
was understand how he was capable of
doing that and i quite quickly realized
the only way i would ever understand how
he was able to do it is if
i'm in that situation yeah which i'm
never going to be
yeah so i let that go quite quickly
um and i don't think it's a good idea to
try and i mean
unless you're studying psychology and
understanding the workings of the mind
which would allow you to empathize i
don't think it's good
to try and understand you know if
something seems irrational or forgive me
for using this word crazy
to you you will drive yourself mad
trying to understand it because they are
not the workings of your mind
and that's not healthy either yeah but
you know just going back to the hyper
awareness thing i think people
will find themselves in situations where
they will call themselves depressed when
actually
they've had something traumatic happen
or something sad happened you know
something sad happens and your cat dies
and you don't want to get out of bed for
two days that's not depression you're
upset
you're dealing with grief and loss
that's normal you know if nothing has
happened
in your life that's traumatic and
everything seems great but you feel
horrendous you know or you can't feel
anything then that's something to be
addressed
um i think we need to be careful of
of everyone diagnosed or not everyone
but people starting to diagnose
themselves with conditions that they
perhaps don't have
i think that's a danger in everything
having to have a tag now and everything
needed in the name and
you know everyone needing to be put in
the box
yeah and and then the way that we treat
people in those
scenarios when we've misdiagnosed them
or to quickly diagnose them
is also unhelpful right i've spent the
last six months working
pretty much full time at a mental health
company in london called tai
and they uh they're a psychedelics
company they're probably the biggest in
europe then
one of the things that came to learn
from working there they're the biggest
in the world sorry not in europe
um one thing i came from working there
but also from reading one of my favorite
books which is up there called lost
connections by johanna hari
was i used to think growing up that um
because this is
what i was told depression was a
chemical imbalance in the brain
because something was broken and no one
ever told me
that trauma or what happened to you can
cause depression so i just you know
you'd think okay well
and that makes you also almost blame
the victim more so than saying like if
it's like what's wrong with you
then it's like it's kind of you know
you're broken but if it's what's
happened to you it's a much more
empathetic approach
and also appreciates you know and that
was the big shift that i've experienced
in the last like
three years was i used to think
everything was just chemical imbalance
broken
yeah you know and then what comes with
that is often how do you fix the
chemical imbalance with chemicals
yeah yeah exactly yeah the best
prescription in the beginning listen
there are some people that will always
need
medical intervention does help
some people it does but i also think
that you know
sayings you are what you eat you can eat
yourself into depression
you know and all of those things they
kind of become part of a
self-perpetuating cycle if i feel like
[ __ ] i
i don't move as much and then i'll make
bad decisions with food and then i feel
about god that's so sad that's so true
but it does because especially during
this time when people aren't as active
as they were they're not engaging
socially
as they would have otherwise um you know
you the sales of alcohol went through
the roof alcohols are depressing the
more you drink the lower you are your
you you know all of these contributing
factors that can contribute to
negative mental health you know and can
negatively impact your mental
well-being um and a great prescription
sometimes
is is you know eating better going for a
walk
you know exercise doesn't have to be a
45 minute hit class that leaves you
wanting to not get out of bed for two
days because that's
you putting your body through another
stress on top of all the stress you're
already going through
um but just you know movement eating
well good conversation
um something i found quite difficult but
has become more apparent is my need to
move away from certain people because
they aren't moving in the same direction
as me
and they encourage certain things that
that hinder my growth
that's not me moving forward my life has
changed and i found that very hard and
you
you know we when you talk about grief
you instantly think someone's died but
you can grieve parts of your life you
know parts of
saying goodbye to certain things certain
people in my life has felt
like the same loss as yeah you know when
i've actually
lost someone who's passed away but you
have to do those things in order
to grow and to get where you want to to
be
and it's it sounds selfish but selfish
has so many negative connotations
attached to it but
i think you know selfishness not at the
detriment of others and selflessness not
the detriment of yourself
is good because how else do you like
you're no good to anyone if you're no
good to yourself
and that was a huge huge learning curve
for me and one that i found really
really
difficult to execute to start making
decisions based upon what was right for
me
because i felt obliged to to be here
for that person and then doing the same
things as those people
um and it wasn't help you know what i
mean and it wasn't helping me
it took me back to this time i met this
monk world famous monk i said
is it bad that i'm focusing on building
my business
and making money um right now is that
like a selfish thing for me to be doing
when i could be off in africa helping
kids
and his response to me who's on stage he
goes he goes you have to fill up your
own bottle so you can pour it out for
other people
and i always remember him saying that
because it you know what the crazy thing
is when i was 18 i i wanted to
i was sat in my moth side in this room
and i was sat there thinking steve
you're making a wrong life decision
because you know you've got a brain and
you know you can like affect
change and the fact that you're trying
to build this business and not
in africa saving even just one life
means that you're being terribly selfish
and my the way that i rationalized
myself out of that state of mind which
was like stopping what i'm doing and
flying to africa was
this belief that if i was to be
successful i would be able to help more
people one day
yeah and it's kind of links to what you
said there about like
selfishness in many cases is actually
selflessness
yeah yeah especially if you you find
yourself in a position later on
where you can you know you can you can
affect change for the better on a much
grander
level you know you have a much bigger
stage now i like guys i love a lot of
the stuff that you say
most of the stuff that you say and i
generally don't like motivational
speakers but i find
when you speak it's motivational which
is quite different
yeah yeah yeah and it's weird because i
don't i
i really don't endeavor to be motivation
it's like most of the time
i am in the gym and i write something in
the notes of my phone and it ends up on
the internet so it's like
yeah i'm not trying to be and also i'm
not like but that's why i'm works
but that's why it works and it's like
whenever i did my documentaries i i i
didn't try and tell anyone else's story
i was just catalyst for them too
it was your truth yeah and it's my
opinions which were formed during the
process of the
the filming i didn't go into it with and
if i went
in sorry if i went into them with any
idea it was often changed and my opinion
was shaped throughout the course of
that documentary i think all too often
people think that by instructing people
or telling them how they should live
their lives they're gonna
impact change and i don't think that's
the best way to engage people i think
people switch off and i think the way in
which you communicate is brilliant
because
you put stuff out there and people can
take to it if if they connect with it
and i think because of that they do
because it's natural and it's organic
and it's not forced
and i think that's really really
important and i think
you know you talk about i don't think
you have to go to africa in order to
impact change because people will be
inspired by watching what you do and are
able to achieve
and that in itself you almost don't have
to
you know you you can just do and you
will inspire yeah this is the crit this
is a crazy thing and you know
the thing we have in our society today
with young people especially is they all
want to change the world
and they think and genuinely i get this
all the time i'll be on stage somewhere
and a kid will come up to me that looks
like me a young black kid and he'll be
like
i want to be a motivational speaker how
do i do
and i i know what the right answer is
because
i know i look at this kid or you know
whether it's one of my instagram dms
that wants to change the world because
they think i think the way i've
rationalized it is they want to change
they don't want to change the world
right
they want to be seen as someone that
changed the world because of the
admiration that they believe they'll get
from that because of the admiration that
they saw me getting
um so in fact they're they're not
connected to the right thing if you're
seeking validation exactly if they
wanted to change the world if that was
their objective they'd actually just be
in
a lab somewhere working on cancer for
example yeah they wouldn't be
trying to get on the stage right but
like you
ending up on stage is a product of the
work you've done you never work to get
onto that i never
wanted never thought about it it was a
byproduct of
working on myself and that's exactly
yeah so thank you actually because i had
lost my train of thought there and you
just picked it back up
that was what i'm saying i got on stage
because i was focused on something else
right
and um the way that people go on to
change the world i think is
because they work on themselves they fix
themselves so that kid my advice
probably to him probably would be like
go and like pursue your passions and in
fact all of my
um idols are on stage because they
didn't copy anybody else they thought
they could make you know
pocket computers and that black was
equal to white in terms of racial
relations martin luther king you know
they
and they they pursued their own thoughts
and their own feelings they they didn't
replicate
um people but then that's the we live in
an age where people
live almost comparatively
you know it's such a shame we have this
incredible thing called the internet
where we can communicate with people in
any corner of the world give or take and
we use it to post facetune pictures
we don't know but you know it's a
there's there's there's a
brilliant tool there and and when
harnessed and used correctly it it can
bring about
good things um and it's like anything
you know like i was eating mcdonald's in
bed last night
i didn't see it on your instagram really
it is on my instagram i'm actually
complaining about the absence of fries
in my large fridge
on my instagram story last night yep
last night i was like let's avoid the
fact that i'm eating mcdonald's in bed
and talk about where the rest of my
fries are i was devastated
why would a large fries if you're going
to get delivered
and then the next one's about gut health
balance bro
that's hilarious that's great balance is
really i think balance is key and i
think all too often
like especially with and and kind of
moving into this sector now anything
that
involves nutrition or or supplementing
or
i [ __ ] hate hashtag wellness world
man like this
it just like that that kind of the
softness of that and the the
the approach to life that just having a
green juice is going to correct
everything it's going to save the world
it's going to save you
like [ __ ] do you know it's it's the
wrong
approach that everything and it i think
everything is too um
it becomes quite divisive you know i i
i believe in wellness therefore i'm not
gonna indulge in any of the things which
i used to find
fun because now i'm going to take care
of myself
me taking care of myself involves me
having a blowout once in a while with my
friends
and suffering the hangover that comes
with it to remind myself why i don't do
it
all the time and the waste of time
afterwards because i can't function
as as as you know as highly as i would
normally you know
um but i just think there's there has to
be a balance struck
it's it's all too often people write if
you want to
you know you can't don't just cut back
on me you have to be vegan
you know there's there's so much
instruction out there whereas
it's all contradictory as well so much
fun so much it is man
and it's like you know you've got vegans
who will you know i mean is is cocaine
vegan how many vegans
how many vegans that go out on a friday
or when we could go out on a friday
night and we'll do cocaine and you know
there's not a gram of cocaine if it
actually has cocaine in it it doesn't
have a dead body attached to it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah where are your
you know what where's your
where is your morn campus now virtue
signaling to
at its finest um you talked about your
documentary
then i one of the things that when i
watched your documentary
really stuck out to me was you recounted
the last conversation you had with your
dad
and um it stuck out to me because
i reflect on my own relationships with
my parents
and i was it made me think about the
last conversation i had with my parents
my parents are getting old especially my
dad
um can you talk a little bit about that
and your feelings towards that
conversation now
yeah so my i'd opened i said i would
never
ever make myself vulnerable as far as my
my dad
again um and by that i mean i would
never give him the opportunity to let me
down
um and then i did uh
and it was just before christmas so we
spoke
and we agreed to meet up the day after
boxing day
um i was
sat at the food quarter the shopping
center in walthamstow
uh my then partner at the time tia i can
remember it so vividly
um and i called him to make arrangements
for the next day
i wasn't driving he had moved to
brentwood um he was driving i said so
are you going to come and
see me tomorrow and he was like oh
mention the name of his uh wife
um now we don't and said oh you know
her and the kids would really love to
see you there are stepchildren there of
no relation to me
um and i was like this ain't about and
this is the first time that i
ever i was always too scared to speak up
to him about how i felt because i
at times blamed myself or worried that i
was the reason that he would disappear
for a year and a half two years at a
time and not seen me
um so i would never speak up and tell
him how much it hurt every time he did
that
and this time i went this is not about
me coming to play happy families this is
about when i was 18.
like this is about you and i sitting
down and having a conversation as adults
and trying to see if there's a way in
which we can move forward and forge some
sort of relationship
with trust um and he was like oh
what actually you know what if you if i
ever see you again
i'm gonna knock you out um and i would
not have bought my eyes out and giving
him a hug
um but i was right to feel that anger
because he had hurt me so
so so much so many times throughout my
entire life
um and that's what i meant about being
cumulative you know it was that constant
it was him being in and out of my life
him being the parent that i
favored him being such a kind generous
gorgeous man but being such a [ __ ]
father
you know that was cumulative it wasn't
any one moment
it was all of the moments that he wasn't
there that he missed that he let me down
all the days spent looking out in my
front room window which looked right at
the bus stop
that he should have got off of a bus at
um to come and see me when he never
showed up
you know it was all of that that added
up to that moment and
people are like wow do you wish you
could go back in time and change what
your last words to
him were no of course not because that
angle was just
i know how could i not be that angry why
should i feel guilt over
his actions or lack of actions
you know i can own that and i'm fine
with it and i don't feel like i should
feel any which way about
saying that to him because i was me
being that angry was justified
i mean like if i don't think a lot of
people would have um
even been trying to rectify the
situation at that point right
and a lot of my friends who won't even
entertain a conversation with their
with their biological fathers or mothers
because they were absent
mm-hmm i have the conversation though
get to a point where where
where where you can let go of and don't
but the
the problem is right they have a
narrative that they have to justify
themselves
and this is something that i've i've
learned so so they have a narrative that
and i still have this with members of my
family now
if we get into that conversation about
the past
they have a narrative which justifies
their every choice
which makes it okay that they have to
have to live with because i haven't
dealt with this [ __ ] yet
they're not going to deal with their
[ __ ] you know if they were going to deal
with their [ __ ] they would have done it
the chances of me getting those people
into
you know through the door to see a
therapist
nil not happening um
me taking that step and sorting my [ __ ]
out doesn't mean that i can sort their
[ __ ] out
it doesn't mean that if i make the room
and give them the forgiveness that
they're going to be able to accept that
forgiveness and be honest with me
because they still have to hold on to
that narrative
to justify their decisions because they
haven't made amends with their decisions
and i can't expect them to yeah they
don't
need that i can't and i can't but i
can't need that because if i need that
i'm always going to be
underwhelmed offended upset let down and
bitter
and i don't want to be any of those
things not least of all now i have a
child that i want
you know the great thing is my child is
born into a world where it's me and my
partner
and she's amazing she's incredible and
has done
you know a lot of the same work that i
have in order to get to the place where
she's at in her life
and we have this peace because we're
able to have open conversations we're
able to discuss things rationally
we're able to be wrong there's room we
make room for each other to be wrong
you know we make room for each other to
be upset
no matter how irrational we give each
other room and space
and time and we're considerate and we're
kind and
we don't you know we we try our best
not to to revert to a child and be
defensive
and offensive because of that um
and you know it is why we have had a
child because we feel safe with each
other
on that point of like moving on so
people in our lives we all have to
to move on from things whether it's a
relationship whether it's trauma whether
it's things that happen but you know
with our parents whatever
um people tend to think that you know
they use this phrase a lot of my friends
were saying at the other day
i just need closure and i i just i
remember thinking oh
for your [ __ ] then if you yeah in fact
you are [ __ ] because what is closure
closure is
insecurity about what happened and a lot
of the time especially in romantic
situations yeah
basically someone has walked out the
door with your self-esteem and what
you're saying is
i can't move on until they come back and
give it to me yeah until they justify
why they cheated or they
explained to me you know because it's
all and they say i was just i think i
wrote on my instagram i was like closure
closure is a choice ultimately closure
isn't you know if you need closure close
the door
yeah you do yeah find closures during
closing the door yeah it is because if
you're constantly
you're still giving over too much of
yourself to someone else
yeah they got keys right yeah like why
are you doing that why are you handing
over that power to someone who doesn't
even want it anymore they've left
yeah you know why are you but then it's
also you can people also find themselves
in this situation where they try and
take responsibility for other people's
actions
it's good to take responsibility for
your actions
if you've provoked something then you
know you can look at maybe being
responsible
for how someone's reacted because you've
prompted that you've provoked that
but trying to take responsibility for
someone else's actions you'll drive
yourself crazy because you can't
take responsibility for everything that
everyone does we all make our own
choices
and that again is is not a good place to
find yourself
and always wanting to understand is like
why
why do we have to understand everything
people make choices we're complex there
are so many
variables in our lives the only thing
you can do is introduce less variables
and that's been quite easy during the
last year because
you know i don't have to walk into
crowded rooms for the people that i
don't know
so when i have socialized when it's been
allowed it's been
amongst people that i want to see
therefore less variables
the situation is more predictable you
know i'm kind of
more aware of the outcome yeah and if
you you apply that to life you know you
if you
we all too often know we we we make
excuses not just for
ourselves and i hate excuses um it's why
i don't like being late to anything
um even if there is a valid reason you
know
it makes me anxious i hate excuses but
we all too often make excuses for other
people
that's just darren you know that's just
how darren is
but there's gonna come a point where
darren just being darren is gonna
have you respond disproportionately
because you've not made clear with
darren that he's overstepping the line
so he's got no idea
and then he oversteps the line the
eighth time and you respond but you
respond for all eight times at once and
darren's
yeah whoa whoa you could have told me
the first time yeah you know and we
could have had a rational conversation
but actually you've allowed it to
escalate to a point where you've
you know held on to this thing that
darren's done every time he's done it
and then
exploded because you're not comfortable
having awkward conversations
because you find them awkward when
actually if someone can't handle a
direct and honest conversation in a
rational conversation
is that someone that encourages you to
be your best self like i don't want to
surround myself with
yay sayers or people who deflect or who
hide from things
i in my life now cannot i don't have the
time for the [ __ ]
i really don't it i like direct
conversations i like friendships where
we are able to be honest
where if my friend you know i don't have
a huge group of friends now i know a
[ __ ] ton of people
but the people that i do like if i if
someone online calls me a [ __ ]
from i don't know greg from skegness i
don't give a [ __ ] he doesn't know me his
opinion of me is made up of
whatever he's read or seen and the dots
that he's joined he's built the resident
[ __ ]
he's yeah in his own [ __ ] that he's
projecting right but
if my best friend felix says stephen
you need to check yourself i'm going to
check myself
you know and it's important to have
those people around you you need to be
able to if you don't have honest
relationships with people and open
dialogue they're not real relationships
it's hard though when you've had some
success right
did you even find that in your own
friendship circle i think i found that a
little bit where because i
i had success and some of my closest
friends actually ended up
they worked at my company and that's how
they became some of my best friends
yeah so i didn't know them before the
company but like what you work with
someone side by side for 10
years and they inevitably yeah yeah and
but i was always the boss so i've always
i've always worried
that because i had that like i was like
the pack leader in my little group of
friends
that they might not check me all the
time when i needed to be checked
right so it's just because they feel
like you know best they know i know best
and because i've always been like the
boss i've always been yeah like i've
always been all in charge i've always
been on leading them as well so it's
like
so for for me stepping into business now
is really important for me to have
um co-workers that will challenge me i
don't want someone that just goes okay
that's not working we'll stop that i
want someone to go yes
that's not that is underperforming at
the moment but given a chance
in two months you're going to see
results from that because you're going
to build and grow your audience
i need educating on that because that's
not my that's not my forte you know
that's not my skill set
um and so you need co-workers and
friends that will challenge you
you know and i believe in challenge
healthy challenge because an opinion is
not an opinion it's an idea until it's
challenged
you know so if i say you know i believe
we should go this way and you say do you
really
and then i explain why i've stood on the
table for it so now it's my opinion and
i know it's my opinion but up until that
point it was just an idea
it was a belief but not necessarily a
correct one and when you started to see
success in your life were there people
in your circle that were
friends people you considered to be
friends that were
clearly not happy for you one of the
best bits of
advice i was ever given was by um a
rapper but he was a friend of mine
skinny man who said to me a real friend
of yours will never be of hindrance to
you and there were definitely people who
weren't as comfortable with me not being
in the same situation that they were in
doing the same things
a lot of people deal with this i got a
call yesterday from one of my best
friends and he said one of my friends is
just complete just unfollowed me on
all the social platforms and i said why
is that because well i think it's
because like i've started to do really
well and he
it's a reflection he thinks it's a
reflection on him he thinks it means
he's a piece of [ __ ] because
i'm succeeding or an attack on yeah this
is just and i i this is a conversation i
don't people don't have enough but at
any point in your life when you
when you divert from the like the path
especially the path that you share with
your closest friends
quite often there will be some kind of
force
from them to try and pull you back to
them yep and say who the [ __ ] do you
think you are stephen
yeah get back in line yeah and have you
did you experience that at any point
where especially when your music career
started to really take off and
it's difficult because you can't take
everyone everywhere
um and there's almost an expectation to
and
i i'm a firm believer in in
opportunity like giving people
opportunities and then
beyond that it's up to them what they do
with that
like i i'm someone who's not i've had
situations with people where i've seen
them have opportunities but they've been
too
insecure to take them because they felt
like they're putting themselves beneath
someone else i don't have that problem
i want to learn from you if you're
further along in your career and i'm
trying to
not mimic what you're doing but i want
to be successful
in the set so you're a musician that's
ahead of me
and you're willing to take me on tour
with you yeah i'm not going to say no to
that because i'm
insecure and i don't want to appear to i
don't want to be the support act i'm
going to say yes because i want to come
along on that ride
and i'm grateful for the opportunity
that you're giving me some people don't
have that mindset
some people don't want to learn from
other people they think they know it all
or
they're they're ultimately scared and
insecure they they feel like they look
smaller
by putting themselves as a support or by
having someone feature on a song or by
accepting help
whereas for me it's always been a you
know like when mike's gonna sign me and
i had the opportunity to go on tour with
him and battle at every stop of his
12 rounds tour when he was at the height
of his success
you know i didn't feel any which way
about doing that i
i was you know i was really really
grateful for the opportunity to go along
and learn in the same way that when lily
said to me oh let me do the chorus on
on just be good to green and we can
perform it live at best of all
in front of 60 000 people bro i was
still selling cocaine
and you know i'd graduated from weed to
coat at that point because i had all of
a sudden after i signed to my skin as
record label
developed this circle of you know model
bookers and
musicians and you know who all took it
and
weed is large and smells a lot coke is
quite easy to move around
and you know i would never have got
caught unless in transit so it became
quite an obvious
decision for me to make because those
things were normalized where i grew up
anyway
i never sold crack or smack because i
don't believe in dealing with people in
the most desperate situations they've
ever been in day in day out
some good news my debut book happy sexy
millionaires just become a sunday times
best seller
um but that's not what i want to talk
about um i just wanted to give
credit where credit is due to fiverr
because all of the assets that i've used
to promote the book like the graphics
the cover photos
assets on instagram some of my stories
have been designed
using freelancers on fiverr.com that's
f i v e r r.com
it's the most cost-effective way that
i've ever found of
flexibly expanding the capacity of my
team
and the quality of freelancers on fiverr
is staggering one of the things i don't
think people appreciate enough
is you can actually also extend the time
zone of your team
by working with freelancers on different
time zones that work while you're asleep
not only is your capacity being extended
but the hours that you're productive as
a team in the day can be extended and if
you've never heard of fiverr or you've
never used it for a project there's a
link in the description below
click on it check it out if you've got
any projects coming up whether it's
podcasting or content or websites or
branding or a voiceover anything
fiverr is your answer when you think of
shoreditch what do you think
um people pissing at people's doorsteps
interesting
that's my home i was i was i was
i was wondering if the just the time
shortage alone would um
would make you think about the sky you
have ah
it's weird man there's there's like i
got hit by a car
in 2013 um yeah it was well i got
squashed between two cars i managed to
get myself up on the bonnet so it was
only my left leg that got caught
the bloke didn't realize his car was in
eco because it was a new car
so it had his foot on the brake which
put the car in eco he took his foot off
the brake as i was walking between two
cars
and he felt the engine start so he
panicked and slammed his foot down but
instead of hitting the brake he hit the
accelerator
um and that was a far more traumatic
event for me
um than being stabbed because that was
really unpredictable nothing came before
that that i contributed to
um when i got stabbed look when i think
i was eight
when chesty someone from my flats who
he don't live in the country anymore um
he got bottled and stabbed and one of my
powers jamal who's younger than me ran
and i might have been nine because i
think james was like seven and he ran
and
called the ambulance for chesty like
this stuff happened you know
um i didn't expect to get that by
someone i didn't know
that i had no history with it it was it
didn't really feel that retribution for
what had just happened
there was a little bit of bickering he
said i bashed his mate it was proper
stupid young bravado
[ __ ] yeah in cargo um and
i just did my ground really was all i
did that was what i did wrong in that
situation if you even think that's me
doing wrong
um in hindsight i could have just gone i
did i didn't barge's mate i said excuse
me and i moved past with an
open hand in a crowded club i was as
polite and as passive as i could have
been and always have been
drunk but he was just on one you get me
so um
but then i did i stood my ground and in
hindsight like now at the age i am and
especially with
you know having a child and just
thinking about how i want him to grow up
and what i want him to understand
being a man to be um you know i could
have just gone
you know what sorry brav i've been done
with it
um but i felt like he was threatening me
and i felt like i was right to stand my
ground i didn't expect that five minutes
after that he'd walk up behind me and
put a broken bottle in my neck
um but at least my my mum and my nan
started talking again
i heard you called your you called your
nan yeah in that moment
yeah so we we were still fighting
outside so he stabbed me i managed to
push him out of the way got a club
holding my neck together obviously
you've got all kinds of
adrenaline running through your body at
that point so you're not really aware of
the
i mean i know i've been poked in the
neck and it's not really
if you're going to get poked you don't
want it to be in your neck
it doesn't you know your chance of
survival is not high
um and then we got the fight got broken
up i think there was police outside the
club i think it was broken up by a plea
the whole thing is a bit blurry to me
and then i was sat on there because i
ended up getting arrested as well um but
i'm sat on the curb my phone's come out
my pocket
um and i can see on everyone's faces
you know this is not this ain't going
well for me
so i asked to pass my phone got my phone
i called my nan and i just apologized
for all the work she had put into me
that this was how it was gonna end um
she just said you're going to be fine
shut up i think she did actually tell me
to shut up
and she's cockney yeah and she just said
you're going to be fine you're going to
be fine
um and she came to the hospital
as did my mom and they both started
talking over my table
that i was on um and it's kind of weird
because when i went to hospital i was
treated like i was some kind of
notorious gang member
that the hospital staff are not
sympathetic to my situation whatsoever
bearing in mind i've been stabbed i
never say i'm a victim because i don't
believe in
approaching life as one um but in that
situation
i i wasn't there the what's the word
perpetrator i wasn't the aggressor
um so it was a bit weird the whole thing
you know to just be
it be presumed that i was just part of
something that came out of nowhere
had nothing to do with no gang nothing
no dealing nothing no
no historic problems from anywhere it
was just something that happened
randomly but no that's not even what i
associate shortage with
um as well as pissing up doorsteps i
think of new balance trainers and
beards yeah yeah do you know when i
listened to that story about what
happened
with uh that guy in the club it brought
me back to a time which i've never
talked about before in my own life where
i was in new york in a club
and there was two tables in this
nightclub and i was on one of them with
a couple of my friends
one of the guys that runs mattress
boxing and there was this table of guys
from jersey next to us
and the guys on my table were talking to
the girls on their table
oh yeah and they they became this
location so i
i know the bouncers in this club because
i get all the time so i said to the
owner and the bouncer i was like there's
going to be a problem here if you don't
move this table and as i'm speaking to
the manager
the guy from the table next to me picks
up a
three liter bottle of vodka and hits me
on the head with it
i am surrounded by so i'm so good with
these bouncers like i've sent the man
united shirts and
i'm like these people know me i'm always
in the club i'm always on the same table
that kind of thing
big bouncer must be [ __ ] seven foot
massive black guy they're my boys we
talk about united every time i come in
there like i'm always
he reaches over the crowd of bouncers
that i'm chatting to just on my table
and he hits me with this bottle of vodka
and i go see
because i was telling them to i was like
there's gonna be if you don't move these
two tables let's get
i go see and as i'm looking blood
because i'm wearing this cat blood just
comes trickling down my face
but again i did nothing to instigate
this this situation and i when i was
reading about what happened to you
and you ended up in hospital and you
know it risked your life
i was thinking what's the lesson here
how do you avoid these situations where
it's variables yeah you know and that's
the thing you
walk into a room like that and there
there are many variables
there's any anything can happen you know
you know and for me i was always like i
was always someone that scanned the room
i always wanted to know i don't like
sitting with my back to doors
never have um i i still have sleep but
when i open is why i've always suffered
with sleep problems i think because of
and that's my own doing to an extent you
know because of some of the stuff that i
used to do and i was by no means like
heavy heavy heavy into things i just
sold a bit of this in a bit of that
because
it enabled me to finance life while i
work towards what i wanted to do if
there was another commodity that i was
aware of that i could have sold that
wasn't
illegal i would have done it um and that
guy he got eight years right
yeah that was a whole bad situation
though because
they moved the trial date when
i was on tour so this was two years
later that it went to court right
um i get a phone call on the friday when
i'm in newcastle
and they tell me when
from a police officer and they told me
when the trial date is and i just said
you know what i'm so
far past that you know i really
don't care like i'm not coming to court
and they said well
we know where you are we know what your
next two tour dates are they were
brighter than london
i think um and we'll issue a summons
we'll arrest you if you don't come to
court yeah
um and i cried bro i was in a conundrum
because
um see this is where
i've never spoken about this this is
where like
my moral compass struggled because you
don't snitch
yeah they had four other witnesses their
dna they had cctv the last thing they
needed in court was me but what did they
get from me being there
they get press um and then i get told by
my record label my tv plug on my radio
plugger that i'll basically be looked at
as an advocate for knife crime
if i don't show up at court but that
goes against everything that i stand for
um in hindsight it's crazy because if i
didn't grow up where i grew up
why would i care about that i didn't do
anything wrong in that situation
but i didn't want to be there i didn't
want to be there
um the whole thing like it
it still troubles me now you know
because
it's like you can't have one foot in one
for art it's like who are you and what
do you stand for
bro i've been arrested before i was
looking at time when i was just before i
started to my skin as record label
and at that point there were other
people involved if i was a snitch i
would
open my mouth then but i found myself in
an impossible situation i'm like i
nearly lost my life
and now i'm being told that i'm gonna
lose everything that i've worked for
if i don't go to court when i got
stabbed
but then it's gonna and listen i've not
lost a friend over it
you know there are people i don't know
that have made comments
um never when i've seen them everyone's
all cool bro
um but it it's weird you know it's still
even to this day it doesn't sit well
with me
i haven't so for all the work that i
have done and all the distance between
me and certain things that that i still
wrestle with
because i was leveraged and it's kind of
mad to think that
you know in that situation they would
have and i mean you only had
it was crazy they wouldn't even so even
to just move the trial date to or you
know for the trial to just
happen during my first headline tour so
i would have missed two gigs as well for
which there was no insurance
and at that point and you won't like to
hear this as good a as good a business
as you are i was actually in two record
deals and it was costing me about 10p to
earn a pound
um so it wasn't like i was you know i
wasn't in a situation where i could
i could weather that storm and this
these weren't times where
where you know that sort of publicity
was good publicity it
there were no rappers on the radio by
like me tiny
chip and and tinchy it weren't you know
it wasn't a given that you could be a
successful artist we were really just
opening them doors
so any negative attention was not not
just hurting me but about shutting doors
for other people as well
but here we are you know i had to go to
court and it's not you know i never
imagined testifying to be something that
i would ever do
but in that situation you know i kind of
used to see that as a black and white
thing but
i guess there's some shades of gray in
between
someone stabs me in the neck on that
caught 10 minutes early
and that's how i should feel you know it
just
but then i also think about all the
other [ __ ] that i've had with the police
and
all the stuff that i've you know that
friends have gone through and look
some if you bring it on yourself and you
put yourself in a situation and you've
got police who abide by the laws that
they enforce all well and good that's
what they believe
you know but there's a lot of police
that that don't
um and i've had you know further
troubles i got nicked in 2013 and was
rebuild and rebuild
lied to in part disclosure lost over a
million pound in endorsements because of
one
being a you know he had a being his
bonnet um
and i was arrested for something i was
never charged for but that never made
the papers everything else did
um so i don't really understand i'm not
saying all police are like that please
have a purpose but when
it's when they take it it's when you
know they start to act out personal
grudges that
you kind of question and the police
please the police right yeah that's the
problem that we have
um but i don't wanna i don't wanna i
don't know don't wanna be better
yeah i remember listening to your music
when i was in
when i was in secondary school a lot and
i remember listening to a lot of your
records more recently as well and
even you know like as as when i know you
were coming in today i started like
going back through my back catalogue of
your music
um at the time when you made it
as you said then in the uk in the uk
hip-hop scene as a white male
that's a [ __ ] staggering
accomplishment like do you know
genuinely it is
i'm like i know a lot because you might
not know this but you're from the jump
off days
yup and i'm all the don't flop boys
they're all best friend friends of mine
like i don't think
you know unanimous i don't know if you
know who you know
they used to come to my house sometimes
for five days in a row and like stay at
my house and they'd rap and stuff
i used to write music back in those days
as well but watching how
talented a lot of these people are at
what they do
and still a lot of them haven't made it
like you did
yeah makes me beg the question it's like
what were the factors that came to play
to make sure that you
as a white rapper in the uk scene
got through um did you know what just
persistence
really persistence persistence i just
didn't stop you know there were so many
full starts as well certainly to mike
skinner's record label
me and him me being lazy
not working as hard as i should have
when um during the period when i signed
to his label
um and i can put my hands up and say
that but us also biting heads and not
agreeing on music
up until a point and then just as we did
and he sent a really kind email and he
was like look i've been spending too
long trying to make you into something
that you're not rather than focusing on
what you're good at
just go um and it was almost at that
point when warner pulled a financing
from his label they were
subsidizing his label they moved
everything in-house apart from all of
this the rest
uh sorry i think it was six seven nine
uh was the label they kept and they
moved that in-house and then they they
pulled the finance in from the rest of
their subsidiaries because of napster
and limewire you know that the money
they were seeing had had fallen
subsequently because of all the piracy
um so the album never came out for two
reasons because the
label lost their financing because i
never worked hard enough
um and then after that i went back to
what i knew
um and what facilitated me being able to
continue
my my quest to become a successful
musician which by the way i thought
would absolve me of everything in my
past
yeah and just make me happy what did you
find out uh i was bullshitting it
what stupid [ __ ] idea that was um so
you thought that becoming a successful
musician would make your part
would put your pass at ease basically
yeah just you just you
and this is what's dangerous about
pinning um your happiness or your
your hopes of happiness on an ever
moving goal post that quite often you
move yourself
if i sell this many records i'm going to
be happy and then you sell that many
records and then it's like okay if i get
a number one single i'm going to be
happy then you get the number one single
and then it's like well what's next
you talked about this earlier you said
about how you've got to enjoy the moment
more
yeah or else you'll never enjoy like
yeah yeah how do you do that though
in the moment um in the moment i don't
like so for me i'm just
it's just it's been a really really long
journey towards not
you know going back to the corners you
can't see around this it's just taking
it for what it is it's like i'm here and
i'm
i'm entirely present my head is not
worrying about the meeting that i've got
to go to afterwards
i'm aware of it because i've seen my
schedule but i'm not
thinking about it and i used to like i
would lay in bed and my mind would be
spinning
spinning spinning about everything that
i had coming up
there's no like it's good to plan like
and i find you worry more if you don't
plan
but i try and look at you know i don't
look at my calendar too far ahead
anymore because it doesn't help me
you know i i want to be present i want
to be able to be here and have a
conversation with you to look you in the
eye and talk to you without having
another [ __ ] in my
head you know an empty head and an open
heart man that's
that's that's how you're present and
they're not the easiest things to
achieve when we all have so much going
on in our lives
and when we're always so like ambitious
because when like as you say the moving
goal post analogy i really like because
i will achieve something today but
before the day of
even achieving it i've already set the
new goal do you know what i mean and so
you never experienced the achievement
and i've i've actually since leaving my
business one of my mentors said to me is
like you just need to
he's that old and he's done it all and
he's way more successful than i'll
probably ever be
and he was like the one advice i'll give
you steve is just like
try your very best to enjoy it in the
moment yeah because you look back on it
with you know rose tinted glasses and
you
you know you wish you would just
savoured it more yeah but you can enjoy
it in hindsight and it is what i was
saying earlier you look back on it and
you go wow i did that
but actually it's the the accolades are
not that important
the the rewards are are there they're
part of it if you're lucky enough to
achieve
but the process is the part of it that
you have to enjoy
and that's the i think that's the
struggle that's why a lot of people
don't necessarily find themselves that
happy because they're not in
situations where they're happy to be
doing the work that they're doing to get
to where they want to be and that's
perhaps because they're in the wrong
place
where they want to be and what they're
doing to get there don't you know they
don't marry up
and we're fortunate we do things we love
we get to pick and choose
that's that's uh you know i was going to
say that's lucky but
it's it's not it's hard work and
perseverance
what do you worry about then these days
um
i mean most recently in the last two
weeks it's been like is that
noise that my son's making in his sleep
normally
so for context uh steven's just had a
new kid yeah
um a new baby boy yeah which is amazing
my first child
um and really you know
just i mean yeah just the thing the
things that i encounter day to day
i i'm not really too i don't know man
like it's weird to be
at this point in my life in my career
about to sign a new record deal to me
putting music out again but to not have
that
like my energy is different i'm just
excited in being able to have a route to
market i've had all this music that
because of
some stupid problems i had with uh the
label i was with
that i couldn't put out i wasn't able to
to
to exercise that part of
you know what i did and that i missed
terribly because that's my output
that's my creative output you know i
enjoy working on
all the other things i'm doing whether
it's a gulp or gizmo
anything all the ideas that i have that
i you know will hopefully come into
fruition later on that i'm chipping away
at behind the scenes
but music is my output that's my hobby
it always has been so when i get
suppressed and i'm not able to
to to work on music or or release music
and they
kind of go hand in hand because it's
kind of weird working on music that you
know you can't release
or that you know someone is standing in
the way of you that you don't feel as
motivated to get in the studio
and work whereas now i'm like i know but
i'm not worried about how it's received
i'm just really happy to be able to put
music out my worries
are not not what they were all the
things i used to worry about
i you know i mean i i don't have
financial security yet
and i'm in a much better place than than
i could have been growing up where i
grew up it wasn't what was expected
um but you know i have to pay my
mortgage i have things like that but
there's
you know they're not worries i have to
work to pay you know that's again you
know work can be a stress or it can just
be work
you know my mortgage can be a stressor
it can just be a mortgage
i just have to work there there's quite
simple things that i have to do in order
to pay my mortgage you know so i try and
not get bogged down by
by the everyday [ __ ] my worries are
uh just whatever pops up and and are
they worries
you know am i getting to to know a child
like am i holding my child correctly
things like that that they're they're my
current
sounds and your new record deal um i i'm
super
intrigued to hear how different your
music will be
now that you've you're in a new phase of
life right yeah and surely that will be
reflected in what you produce
yeah i think there's uh you know we've
spoken about grief
and loss and letting go of things
throughout this whole conversation and i
think
there's part of professor green that
he's still there that still wants to be
a lippy little [ __ ]
that still wants to poke and prod and
i don't know in the age of cancer
culture i probably need to watch my
mouth but it's not something i've ever
been good at
but then there's also the more mature
side then i think there there will be
a point between now and perhaps an album
that i have in mind that i've started
working on
that there's a bit in between where i
need to just get a little bit of that
angst out
and i think there is a transition to
take place that will happen throughout
the music
because things are different and when
can we expect to hear this music
um i'm having something out this summer
whether i can tour it or not due to
carving who knows
but amazing how do you feel about that
must be
must be all kinds of feelings bro just
happiness
yeah yeah proper because i've been
sitting on this music for ages and then
having the conversations with the label
that i may sign to
they hear the music and they pull out
the songs which i would have hoped they
do
you know and they're not necessarily the
most obvious and it's kind of cool to
have that
or the beginnings of that working
relationship um
and it it makes me excited about the
music that i've been making and i've
been sitting on which sometimes you know
these songs are not new to me but they
will be to everyone else
so to have someone kind of re-light that
fire it's amazing yeah
and a gulp a gulp so i'm gonna try this
now explain to me what it is while i try
it
okay so i have a whole lifetime
of gut issues um most recently in 2017
i had an operation to repair a hiatus
hernia oh
sorry i should have done this a bit more
and when i came out of hospital after
the the operation went well
there's the gulp yep
yummy when i come out the opera i come
out of uh surgery and the surgery had
went well but i had terrible
complications
i had distension alias um
collapsed lung pneumonia crp which is an
information marker of 672 which is
i understand the looks on the surgeon's
faces
um and i nearly cropped it and then i
the the alternative
the op sorry the options that i had were
more surgery or
leave hospital with a paralyzed stomach
and just hope it got better over time
and so i didn't want to chance more
surgery because i was more likely to
have the same complications again
so i started looking at ways i could
treat myself more holistically
um and this was an education for me i
found myself down at every rabbit hole
you know i've been down every rabbit
hole you could ever imagine and then
and continuously still researching
actually what i found out is the more
consistent i was with looking after my
gut by the
mcdonald's um is that the the better my
mood was the more consistent my mood was
the better i
slept the better i felt the more
consistent my energy was
and it's just it's unbelievable how
how much your gut health contributes to
every other pillar
of of your well-being and how much your
gut health is also impacted by them so
your sleep impacts your gut your gut
impacts your sleep
it's it's all interconnected so what
exactly
so i've just i've just had one of these
um sachets that i've got here in front
of me yeah i go up and
what is this going to do for me in like
dumbass terms in dumbass terms so that's
feeding your gut
um bacteria what it needs to thrive and
it's also packed with vitamins that
support
your healthy gut lining sure you know
which help prevent or repair a permeable
gut
and how often do i take one of these
every day every day everyone a day yup
okay a lot of people have got issues and
they don't understand
why i'm one of them i've probably in the
last increasingly over the last five six
seven years i've got
this sort of clear intolerance to
something it's definitely like i can't
eat bread pasta without feeling it for
like
two three days um and i and it's weird
because i just kind of trundle through
life
feeling like [ __ ] sometimes and not
really doing anything about it or
getting tested or
yeah that's the thing with like i think
especially with gut health and there's
there's just health problems in general
like a lot of people go through life
just feeling run
down because it's because we're not edgy
yeah and it's
it's just accepted and i think that's
that's a real problem and i think
there's a lack of education and that's a
really
important part of a gulp you know it's
not just us trying to sell these sachets
it's the educational piece which is
really important because people should
understand
what they what they can do in order to
thrive it
you know you can live and be alive or or
you know you can
you can optimize parts of your health
and well-being so you don't have to have
that trip to the doctors rather than
i'm i'm all for proactivity whether it's
your mental health or your physical
health you said to me before we started
recording that you um
you spent your whole career like being
the product yeah and now you're
you're the guy in the boardroom yeah the
proverbial boardroom
on the other end of zoom um what's that
change been like now you're an
entrepreneur running a business
um dealing with all of that [ __ ]
i'm so happy you said it no i mean it is
[ __ ] right there's like copious
amounts of [ __ ] when you're running
a company
um how have you found that process
business for me
i think things are all too often over
complicated
um and i there will always be problems
but it's like solutions i like solutions
for me it's
it's been a pretty steep learning curve
but i enjoy learning i'm happiest when
i'm learning
and i'm learning an awful lot um and
it's
it's quite nice being in the engine room
um
it's nice to have ownership you know
that's something that i haven't really
had as an eyes
what parts do you hate what parts do i
hate i see i like problem solving but
sometimes when problems present i don't
like being presented with problems when
there's
not even an idea of a solution sure and
i think there's if you take half an hour
between making between finding out the
problem and making me aware of the
problem you can probably have thought of
something that can contribute to the
solving of that problem
um and the immediacy the panic
i don't like panic i don't want a power
you know i don't want the culture in our
firm to be one of
panic you know i want people to take
ownership i think ownership's important
i think
accountability is important um and not
to be punished
just so as you can own it put your hand
up grab [ __ ] it but i fixed it and
take some [ __ ] pride in that
and there's a certain type there's
several types of people i'm sure you'll
encounter in your business where you've
got one type of person who i usually say
from a business partner
they will like solve the problem and
handle it
before they even come to me and they'll
just come to me and say steve by the way
this has happened but don't worry
i'm on it fix it don't worry i love that
type of person i'm like promotion
promotion promotion
and then this other type of person
who'll be like steve the office is on
fire the office is on fire i'm all gonna
die
and they're just screaming in my face
like the office is on fire and you're
gonna die and i'm gonna die and it's all
over
we're finished we're [ __ ] we're [ __ ]
yep and that person can never be a
manager
because if they can't manage themselves
they can't manage anyone else here and
i and this is a hiring thing because
i've seen both in my business
and i will always promote the people who
caught they grab hold of problems
extinguish them
before i even realized it was a problem
amazing amazing individuals
but then you wanted to have i think
there's a third person as well and
and and that's where apathy comes into
it and it's like they're um the room's
on fire and i'm watching it burn but i
don't really feel any need to leave or
to tell you
yeah we can just die here but you know
we won't even worry about putting the
fire out
yeah yeah yeah that's the problem even
worse
i prefer the panic over the absolutely
it's like he's like do be panicked
yeah and please try and find the
solution before you know
not that i want to wash my hands of all
of it i want to work i want to
understand
that's one thing i've always been as
meticulous with anything that i've done
outside of music as i am with every word
that i write i think you know
i i saw a post that you put up about the
details
yeah and i i agree and you know this
whole the devil's in the details and
people get really annoyed with me
or can get annoyed with me throughout my
life in every aspect of it being really
obsessive
over the manuscript but that's that's
[ __ ] important
those little things i agree
wholeheartedly
you know again cumulative all of those
little things add up to make that one
big yeah
and for me especially in brand comms
like i want it to be communicated in a
certain way because and our
communication has been my thing i talk
through my music and i want to talk
through my product in the same way
yeah i i was just very detail-orientated
my whole life but i think the problem i
had is i never really explained to the
people that i was talking to why i cared
so much about details
so i'd say look that's not right well
that little thing there is that
symmetrical and i the amount of times
that i've got a ruler out in social
chain
my company and i'd measure something to
check the millimeters on both sides of
it
and those little things i think people
think you're being anal or whatever but
it's
it's a philosophy yeah that if you have
within yourself about
high standards being obsessant about
detail as i said in my post yesterday
it's those that those small details
culminate to great things right so
i'm just like these days i don't give a
[ __ ] like i
i'm i want to be detail-oriented i want
people to feel that i'm so
detail-oriented
that they won't show me something until
they've been equally detailed and
orientated yeah and that's
kind of a culture and a philosophy of
weakness
is the right type of culture it's caring
yeah you know we're a very small team
you know we've we've been hitting some
pretty punchy targets month and months
since we launched in october
yeah ahead of our first race oh wow um
yeah yeah big balls either that or i'm a
[ __ ] idiot
um i did wonder but it's that that's the
culture that i want to promote and
it's like you have to i like what you
said because i think it's important you
can't just keep pointing out what's
wrong you have to explain why it's
important that it's right
you know not just saying that's wrong
fix it i think it's important that if
you know how to fix it you explain how
to fix it but also why it needs fixing
you know people should be learning on
the job all the time so as they can grow
into roles that they may never have been
employed for um you know i've grown into
a position
i don't think i was i was you know ever
you know as a child probably looked at
being
destined to be you know not from where i
was from
um and i'm continuously growing into
that role
because i want to learn and i have to i
have to keep learning otherwise i don't
see the point in continuing that to me
is like
you know people talk about about death
death to me is
is is losing that that i don't know just
just
not being curious not wanting to learn
not wanting to understand
yeah i see that's something i've come to
learn as well you know you talked about
the goal post moving and that and the
importance of curiosity it's one of the
things i talk about in my book is like
i came to realize at some point that my
life the purpose of my life was probably
just to keep myself in like forward
motion
of like chaos that's the way i describe
it it's like i used to think stability
was chaos and careful stability now i
know that my stability is actually being
in chaos which is
exactly what you said there like being
curious being challenged
um until i die someday and like which
happens to all of us yeah
yeah some some sooner than others if
they
they don't get to ever really live look
after their gut health
yeah there you go well listen steven
thank you so much for coming here today
you know your story
is remarkable because um you're someone
that is like unashamed
unashamedly honest about everything and
that
transparency and honesty has helped
[ __ ] i can't even imagine the amount
of people it's helped even the the
rawness and the openness of you doing
that documentary
i mean you see it on the documentary you
see how
being open and honest and expressing
yourself can
save people and i know you're i know
you're [ __ ] i think of all the guests
i've sat here with i think if there was
one guest who i think has probably
saved more people from themselves from
their thoughts it's got to be you so
it's a great tremendous uh service
you've done to
get rid of when people say kind of no
but it is like getting my belly button
right now
but i was watching it and i was thinking
you know this is exactly what the world
needs especially at the time when it
came out and uh
in terms of people that have the
experience to to say these things you
know you're
a rapper you know i mean do you know
what i mean it's it's
rapper documentary exactly
at that point like the perception of you
when you made that documentary was like
this is a tough guy rapper that comes
from
you know the ends or whatever and for
you to be talking about those things in
the same way that rio ferdinand
crying and crying right having the
having the
the i'd call it courage but you know
it's a strange word to use but having
the courage to be that vulnerable i
think is just such a tremendous service
you've done so
thank you because you know i just think
it's like the most important thing
is you've been part of a change uh
you've been part of this change over the
last couple of years in mental health
and men
specifically talking about how they feel
and that is [ __ ] how that is a
moment i think we'll look back on in
history and say
like thank god we realized that you know
i hope so
i think we need to really encourage
people to to stop applying behaviors to
genders you know i shouldn't have to be
called a girl for being sensitive why
should only women be afforded the right
to be
emotional or emotional beyond anger yeah
thank you brother i appreciate you thank
you good pleasure thanks
[Music]
um
[Music]
you